what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today is a great day
because we got the official teaser
trailer for Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania and it did not disappoint at all
there is so much in this trailer there's
a lot to break down and a lot to
theorize about we're going to be
covering it all in a bunch of videos
this week but in this video I want to
talk about some very very important
details that you need to know to know
what exactly is happening in this
trailer so let's not waste any time and
let's just jump right into it now the
beginning of the trailer is pretty much
just Ant-Man kind of being famous now
after the events of Avengers endgame
obviously Ant-Man was an Avenger and he
helped save the world and half of the
Universe from Thanos and in fact if it
wasn't for Ant-Man getting stuck inside
of the quantum realm in the first place
The Avengers would have never figured
out how to go back in time they would
have never gotten the stones and they
would have never been able to reverse
the snap so Ant-Man played a big part in
that in The Avengers are all now famous
and we learned this in doctor strange
and the Multiverse of Madness where Dr
Strange says we could use an Avenger and
he tells Wanda that she could get back
on a lunch box telling us that the
Avengers are so famous they are actually
on lunch boxes and have toys and a bunch
of other things as we see in this
trailer we can actually see one kid has
an Ant-Man backpack Scott passes him by
high-fives him and the kid is ecstatic
now as he walks by you can see a bunch
of people looking at him they clearly
recognize him he's famous we can see him
walking down a red carpet with hope we
can also see that he's a Baskin Robbins
employee of the century in Ant-Man 1
that is where he worked when he got out
of jail and then we hear a worker from a
coffee shop tell him thank you
Spider-Man now I'm pretty sure this is
just a gag for the trailers I'm sure
most people know that Scott Lang is
Ant-Man especially after Spider-Man no
way home where everybody forgot that
Peter Parker was Spider-Man nobody knows
who Spider-Man is right now but the
point of the beginning of this trailer
is that Scott Lang is actually quite
famous now for being Ant-Man we then
quickly cut to a shot of Scott with his
daughter Cassie Lang and you may notice
that the actress who used to play her
has been replaced we now have Catherine
Newton playing Scott's daughter Cassie
Scott and Cassie are with hope Janet Van
Dyne and Hank Pym and we find out that
Cassie has made a device that sends a
signal inside to the quantum realm and
notice how immediately Janet Van Dyne
who was trapped in the quantum realm for
years and years and years she begins to
freak out and for good cause because
they all get sucked into the quantum
realm not too long after by the device
now from here we see that the group is
now separated from what we've seen in
the trailer it looks like Janet Van Dyne
Hank Pym and hope are together while
Scott and Cassie are together which
makes sense because Scott and Cassie did
go in a little bit after them because
they were both holding on a little bit
longer now from here we get a look at a
lot of different new characters a lot of
different what looks to be civilizations
inside of the quantum realm we hear
Janet Van Dyne say there's a secret
Universe beneath ours and it kind of
seems like Marvel Studios is trying to
trick us a little bit here making making
us think that this universe is something
different than the quantum realm but it
is the Quantum realm the film after all
is titled quantumania and here's the
thing about the quantum realm it looks
like Kang the Conqueror has already
conquered the quantum realm and it seems
like Janet Van Dyne knows that remember
she spent 30 plus years inside of the
quantum realm she definitely knows what
dangers lie ahead of them and she knows
that King the Conqueror is the one in
charge we even see a group of people go
up to Scott and Cassie and it looks like
they're going to take them somewhere we
even hear hope ask her mother what are
you so afraid of and she seemingly
replies with there's something I never
told you and this is where we actually
see King the Conqueror for the very
first time in an extremely comic
accurate suit might I add now we
actually don't see all of him we just
kind of see him from the Torso down he's
holding some type of orb it looks like
an energy source and he puts it inside
of something this could be one of keng's
weapons that he's known for using in the
comics and we're about to dive into who
King exactly is right now now after we
see King the Conqueror putting this
energy source into this object we see a
huge highly Advanced City and this city
seemingly has an army and I believe this
to be chronopolis chronopolis is where
Kang lives in the comics it's in limbo
which exists kind of outside of time and
space and in the comics it has access
points to all of the time errors that
King has conquered now as some people
may know we've actually met Kang the
Conqueror before or at least a variant
of him and that is he who remains from
Loki and if you haven't seen the Loki
series you're definitely going to have
to watch that before watching Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania at least you
have to watch the finale of Loki you see
Kang the Conqueror and he who remains
was originally a person named Nathaniel
Richards Nathaniel Richards is
originally from the future he's a
scholar of the 31st century and he's a
descendant of Reed Richards aka Mr
Fantastic of the Fantastic Four
Nathaniel discovers time travel
technology created by Victor Von Doom
AKA Doctor Doom who is also revealed to
be another possible ancestor of his in
the comics he uses the time travel
technology to travel back in time to
ancient Egypt and he becomes the Pharaoh
Rama Tut however his rule is cut short
when a Time displaced Fantastic Four
arrive and defeat him and from there he
gets pretty pissed off he travels
forward again to the 20th century where
he meets Dr Doom and he now redesigns
his own armor based off of Dr Dooms
calling himself now the Scarlet
Centurion he then goes to battle The
Avengers but they manage to force him
away from their own timeline he then
tries to go back home but he overshoots
the 31st Century by a thousand years and
from here he discovers a very different
Earth it's a war-torn earth it's
basically destroyed and in ruins the
people are still alive however they do
not understand the weapons that Kang
uses because they forgot how they worked
so Kang manages to easily conquer this
world however since the world is pretty
much dead he desires to conquer a
different Earth and this is where King
the Conqueror is born so from here Kang
travels through multiple different
points in time conquering multiple
different Earths and of course he can go
into different universes as well and
this is the villain of Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania who we are introduced
to in this trailer king the Conqueror
now in Loki he who remains kind of
explained the MCU backstory he said that
in the 31st Century a variant of himself
of course that is Nathaniel Richards who
I just explained and he explains that
this variant discovered that there were
universes stacked on top of his own and
other variants were discovering this at
the same time so they eventually all
made contact with each other and at
first there was peace and he says that
they actually helped each other they
shared technology and helped each other
grow but then he says that not every
version of him was so pure of heart he
said to some of the variants new worlds
only meant new worlds to conquer and
then an all-out multiversal war broke
out and then it was almost the end of
the Multiverse as they knew it and then
essentially he who remains that specific
variant harnessed the power of eliaith
and basically defeated everybody else
made the TVA and made it to where there
was only one timeline and only one Kang
he who remains however of course as most
of us know Loki and Sylvie ended up
killing he who remains essentially
shattering the one sacred timeline
busting open the Multiverse yet again
and he who remains explained that if
they killed him his variance would be
Unleashed and they would come and they
would be worse than him and that's who
we're dealing with now Kang the
Conqueror and as you can see the city
that he has built here inside of the
quantum realm is massive it is huge and
it actually does resemble the city that
we saw inside of the TVA a little bit
and Kang is actually already killed
Ant-Man in several other universes and
Kang actually drops a line in this
trailer that leads us to believe that
ant-man's time might be up pretty soon
and king of course knows this because
he's a time traveler he is the time
traveler the master of time so he's seen
ant-man's future I'll explain this in
just a bit but first big thank you to
Mint mobile for sponsoring this video
most people know about mint mobile
because of Ryan Reynolds but most people
don't know about mint Mobile's amazing
quality now I live in the mountains and
service isn't too good however mint
mobile sent me a free plan and I get
better service with their plan than I do
with my other provider but what's crazy
is their plan is so much cheaper mint
mobile offers Wireless for just 15 bucks
a month they give you the best rate
whether you're buying for one or a
family and at mint mobile families start
at only two lines all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5G Network plus mint Mobile's Modern
Family Plan lets you mix and match data
plan so everyone gets the amount of data
that's right for them and you can use
your own phone and keep your same number
and contacts so to get your new Wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month including
the Modern Family Plan go to
mintmobile.com Cosmic that's
mintmobile.com Cosmic cut your wireless
build down to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com Cosmic now in this
trailer we hear Kang say this place
isn't what you think now he is seemingly
speaking about the quantum realm but
what exactly does he mean by this place
isn't what you think well like I
mentioned the headquarters for king and
the comics is chronopolis which is what
we're seeing here so I think King is
referring to the fact that the quantum
realm isn't just some other universe
that people can explore but it's the
home base of King the conqueror's Army
and it's sort of the Hub that exists
outside of time and space where Kang can
access all of these different points in
time and access other universes as well
now like I mentioned Kang is in charge
of everything however it seems like he
needs Scott's help now they originally
showed an Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania trailer at d23 and sdcc this year
and this trailer although it does
contain some of the same scenes is
actually different some parts were left
out of it now what we've learned from
the other trailer is that this is sort
of a Time Heist movie where King gets
Scotland to steal something for him and
Kang basically holds Scott's daughter
Cassie hostage until Ant-Man does what
he wants and I think this has to do with
that power source that I mentioned in
the beginning of the trailer this is why
Kang needs that power source it's
actually revealed in this trailer very
briefly if we take a look at this scene
right here we can see King on some type
of platform on the right of it we can
actually see the device that King had
before and it looks like it is indeed
powering this platform now this platform
is actually something very very specific
I believe that this is Kang's time chair
in the comics Kang's timeshare is you
guessed it how Kang travels through time
and it also has advanced Weaponry on it
including some lasers and an incredibly
powerful shield and I'm thinking that
somebody one of these random people that
we've seen in here will talk about Bill
Murray's character in just a bit might
have taken a power source from King and
he might sort of be stuck in the quantum
realm right now without that power
source which is why he wants it back now
before we dive into why I think
ant-man's time might be running out soon
let's talk about Bill Murray's character
because I love Bill Murray and I'm so
excited he's in this film it's been
confirmed that Bill Murray is playing a
character by the name krylar now in the
comics krylar does exist in the
microverse aka the quantum realm and the
MCU and he has made a machine that
generates a physical form of anybody's
worst fears now Bill Murray did say that
he is playing a villain in the film so
this person probably has a relationship
with Kang however I would not be
surprised if he's actually a hero and
he's simply pretending to work for Kang
Beyond his side but is actually good and
it has been revealed that krylar and
Janet Van Dyne did kind of have a
relationship together inside of the
quantum realm so we're gonna see how
that plays out but I'm assuming that
Bill Murray's character is going to at
least turn good because of Janet in this
film now in the trailer shown at sdcc
and d23 we heard Kang dropped a very
very powerful line Ant-Man says
something along the lines of you
shouldn't mess with me I'm an Avenger in
which king replies you're an Avenger
have I killed you before now again
remember Kang is the master of time
travel and not just in one universe but
the Multiverse and he can live thousands
and thousands of years in fact when he's
about to die he can transfer his
Consciousness into a different variant
of himself so he is essentially Immortal
so he's killed many Avengers before and
he probably has killed a variant of
Ant-Man before as well and he might have
even seen the end of our specific
Ant-Man which is why I think he drops
this very specific line he says I can
get you home and give you more time now
as he says this we see Ant-Man running
and he sees a giant version of Ant-Man
kind of get killed like Mr Fantastic
does in Multiverse of Madness basically
turned into string cheese now this could
be the result of krylar like I said
krylar invents a machine that basically
can generate a physical form of
anybody's worst fears or this could
maybe be Kang showing Ant-Man his future
which is why Kang is telling Scott he
can help him he can give him more time
if Ant-Man helps him and like I
mentioned based off of the other footage
that was shown at sdcc and d23 we know
that Kang wants Ant-Man to get something
back for him and it's interesting that
the very last line of this trailer is
Kang calling Scott Lang Ant-Man and this
is very intentional because remember in
the beginning of the trailer he got
called the wrong name Ant-Man got called
Spider-Man but by Kang calling him
Ant-Man it implies that he does really
know him and again he knows him because
of time travel he's probably met Scott
many times before and probably has
killed his variants so that's it for the
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania teaser
trailer I have so many more theories
about what's going on so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
future videos one is coming out tomorrow
and be sure to let me know your thoughts
on the trailer in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
for live updates you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf